you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video
three from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
an approach to thinking about chess a
structured way to think critically about
the game so that you can help yourself
to improve your understanding of the
game now I have four things in mind when
I'm referring to this structured way of
thinking and it runs as follows the
first is to simply be curious about the
game to ask yourself a question about
the game a relevant question one where
once answered or if answered you will
have a better understanding of the game
or will have improved your play in some
way the second is to make observations
to gather information about your
question brainstorm use some reasoning
see what you can come up with third is
draw a conclusion what is some idea that
you have based on the information you've
gathered and the reasoning you've used
come up with some theory and lastly test
your conclusion
does it carry any substance does your
theory hold any weight might we consider
it a general principle something that
can act as a guideline for our own play
now let me give you an example of what
I'm referring to here let me put this
into context suppose you're curious
about the following suppose you'd like
to know what squares are good squares
for our night it's a perfectly
reasonable question let's investigate it
further okay what do we know about the
night okay well here are some things for
one he moves in an L dirrection okay
basic point system relative value for
the night he's worth three points and he
has a jumping ability now keep in mind
I'm not sure this information I'm
gathering right now will be so helpful
to us but I'll nevertheless be
considering
it we're not sure how it will apply or
if it will apply another thing we can
say well if we're curious about what
good squares there there are for a night
or what squares are good squares for a
night ahh
how does the night stand on each square
what does the night do on each square of
the board now what I have mapped out is
the maximum number of moves a night has
from every square on the board what we
can observe here something we can say
from this information we've gathered and
this is primarily only based on the
mobility of the night is that he has a
lot of options towards the center of the
board and these central 16 squares he
has eight options and in chess the more
options the better when it's your turn
to move so we'd like to have our pieces
maximized a night standing in the center
a theory one we might have based on this
information is that the night does well
in the center of the board now if you're
to test that out what you're going to
find is that it does carry a good weight
okay it does have substance we may very
well regard that as a general principle
it is a well-known general principle
that the night stands well in the center
of the board this is nothing new
okay I'm just trying to share with you
something right here this example I gave
is one where we took something we
already knew the night's mobility and we
derived from it a better understanding
of the night we now have a better sense
of where the night belongs in the game
now the more interesting question this
is this is what I found to be quite
interesting is that the more questions
you ask we find out new things about the
game for example if we're to ask a
similar question only now in the case of
the queen or in other words what squares
are good squares for a queen let's see
what that leads
- doing a breakdown about the Queen she
moves like a rook and Bishop well in the
case of the night we found that that
wasn't so helpful to us knowing that the
way a piece moves was not so important
to us the basic point system for the
Queen she's worth nine and also okay
looking at the mobility of the Queen or
once again seeing in the case of the
Queen the maximum number of moves here
that the Queen has from every square on
the board similar to the knight
the Queen is having a maximum number of
moves in the center in fact if we looked
at all pieces the bishop we could see
its mobility if we have a look at the
rook we could see its mobility on the
board and even the king we could have
these breakdowns on board and seeing
where it's well placed all pieces tend
to be well placed in the center now
still looking at the Queen here
what theory might we be able to come up
with based on this information well we
can also have this idea that the Queen
does well in the center now if we're to
test that conclusion let's see about
that what we're going to find and what's
well known already just like in the case
of the night the night does well in the
center but the Queen she does not and
why is that the case if we're running
out towards the center with the Queen
just starting the game when we bring the
Queen out very early we're going to find
that our opponents Knights our
opponent's bishops
these lesser valued pieces will give her
a problem they will attack the Queen and
she will be having to react and that is
not a good position to be placing
yourself in where you're constantly
reacting to your opponent's threats the
knight did not have that problem did he
he's able to go in the center he doesn't
have anybody that could really
away any piece that can scare him away
if he's attacked with an enemy night he
doesn't necessarily have to run away we
could support him with upon a knight a
bishop any other piece same thing if
he's attacked with a bishop we have that
option of supporting the knight the
Queen does not have that luxury now this
new question this what squares are good
squares for a queen that we find she
doesn't stand well in the center but
this might raise an even more
interesting question is there ever a
time where the Queen stands well in the
center there is a good answer to that
now how we might find that out is
looking back about our understanding of
the night well he stands well in the
center because he has a lot of options
why is the Queen not standing well in
the center she has a lot of options as
well the difference between the two and
differences in chess is a very big deal
this will lead us to making new
discoveries and developing a better
understanding of the game
finding differences the difference
between the knight and the queen is that
the knight is fearless very few pieces
that can attack him and you know he
doesn't necessarily have to run away the
Queen does okay she does have to run
away when she's attacked by these minor
pieces so is there ever a time that the
Queen is well placed in the center yes
in certain conditions
she is excellently placed in the center
what might those conditions be well if
the only thing holding her back from
being close to the center are lesser
valued pieces attacking her
what about positions where there aren't
so many lesser valued pieces that can be
attacking her suppose there are no minor
pieces well what we can be saying here
just showing sharing with you an
abbreviated or a fast-forwarding instead
of going through this whole
right down again what we can be
concluding here is that the Queen will
stand well placed in the center or it's
more likely I should say it's more
likely the Queen will stand well in the
center as more and more pieces are
exchanged off the board okay now we
started off with something very basic
here just as a close we started off with
something very basic we took something
we already knew the question related to
the night and his mobility what squares
are good for a knight we derived from it
a better understanding of the night we
know he stands well in the center this
led to another interesting question like
in the case of the Queen in her mobility
and this of course drew some attention
to certain conditions when exactly is
the queen well placed in the center okay
again just a breakdown here of the
bishops mobility he's a little bit more
difficult to describe
he's quite often well placed working
from afar the rook as we could see not
so much excitement for teens everywhere
and similar to the Queen he doesn't have
a great place in the center of the board
not only because he's not necessarily so
well placed any better in the center
than he is anywhere else on the board
but he's also of greater value than
those minor pieces and the King well
he's the most valuable he should stay
far away from the center at least at the
very early stage of the game so again
just that quick breakdown a structured
frame of mind
our structured way of thinking about the
game to simply be curious make
observations draw conclusion test your
conclusion see we come up with I'm sure
there are plenty more more interesting
questions than I've thrown at you in
this video but nevertheless I hope it is
helpful to you as you try to think
critically about the game and try to
improve your understanding of the game
so that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it and I
will catch you in video 4 take
by
you